okay you got eyes on the bar  yep  here he comes  and i got the dealer  nino they're heading your way  they're here you should have eyes on the  merchandise  i sure do  [Music]  was that a gunshot  ah they shot the dealer  that is so unprofessional  can we do this we can't afford not to  nina you good yeah let's do it great  whenever you're ready kevin what are you  guys thinking for dinner tonight how  about my whole famous chili con carne  [Music]  hey guys what you got in the  oh  stolen marshall mdi-101 m9 multi-rocket  shoulder launchers nice  my buddies and i have been looking all  over town for this have you been  hoarding  see we need them for our startup it's a  criminal empire  up  [Music]  [Music]  one two three  [Music]  um  [Music]  you should buckle up  ugh  [Music]  get the [ __ ] away from my friends  [Music]  [Applause]  you